Hey, everyone. Welcome to our
newest
episode of
Metal Mondays where we're gonna get down and
dirty with the Equinix metal.
Today, we're gonna show you how to automate
your server deployments using
Terraform, Pulumi,
and Ansible.
We've got a couple of my good colleagues
here, David McKay and Jeremy Tanner, if y'all
wanna go on and join me.
Alright. And I think, McKay, you're gonna kick
us off with Terraform first. Right?
No. But I will kick us off with
Pulumi. Oh, cool. You're gonna kick us off
with Pulumi, then Jeremy's gonna come in with
Terraform. Alright.
Okay. Let me share my screen.
So we should now
see my terminal.
So I'm gonna start from absolutely nothing
and walk through the process of creating a
new Pulumi project.
There's a couple of choices of languages.
I'll see how brave I'm feeling and then
we'll try and add some bare metal servers
to the configurations, spin them up and see
what happens. So
we're gonna start with just running Pulumi new,
which is like an interactive,
you know, CLI that tries to give you
a hint about what you wanna do.
So I'm just gonna jump down to show
additional templates and you'll see down the bottom
when my cursor catches up. We have a
couple of packet ones that are available. Now
the provider hasn't been renamed to Equinix metal
but it is something that we're working with
the Pulumi team to rectify.
So you can see we could just go
JavaScript, Python or TypeScript. I quite like Type
Script. I like the really strong typing capabilities.
I think it makes the code a lot
cleaner. So I am gonna go with that
one today.
Now let's get that a slightly better name
than the temp directory that I'm in. So
we'll call this metal
Monday
and the default description is fine.
We don't need dev, let's go straight to
production.
No.
One thing is gonna fail because I'm an
idiot. So let's drop that out and what
I need to do is Pulumi login local.
So Pulumi, if you're familiar with Terraform and
other systems like this, they store their state
file in a remote location.
Pulumi was configured to store my state and
to a location which is currently blocked off
by a firewall, if not firewall, a VPN
and I'm not on the VPN.
So it was timing out.
So I'm just gonna start again.
And run through Pulumi new once more.
Why is the director not empty? There we
go.
So now I'm just using local state because
I don't actually wanna put it anywhere because
I'm not gonna persist this project.
We'll call this better Monday again.
Production
production
metal.
I've obviously done a demo similar to this
before. Now Pulumi is really cool
and that we can store our secrets
inside the
current project and they are encrypted with a
key and a salt.
Which means that you can have everything that
you need. You know, you don't need to
go to your CI server and configure environment
variables to pass in secret information. You can
store them in GET because they're secure. Now
I wouldn't recommend using the password protected approach
that I've just used here.
You can hook it up to KMS systems
in the cloud,
which is really nice including vault, which is
probably the preferred option.
So what does our Pulumi create? Let me
pull over code,
which went to the wrong window.
That size please.
Cool. So let's have a look. By default,
we get index
dot ts
which
is just a typescript file and it
essentially assumes that you wanna create a project
by default.
I'm gonna reuse a project so that we
can show how to inject arbitrary configuration enter
Pulumi and then just spin up a device.
So what I'm actually gonna do is just
remove this at first.
So now we wanna pass in some configuration.
Now to do that, we can do a
Pulumi config set and I can say project
ID
and it's gonna ask me for the value.
Now over my other window here, I do
have my project ID. Now this is not
secret.
So I'm gonna paste it straight in as
such. Now all it does is enter Pulumi
environment YAML,
store it here available so that can be
consumed within our TypeScript code.
Now I do want to add a secret.
I wanna be able to add our Pulumi
auth, our packet auth token.
So
now because this is secret, we add the
dash dash secret flag
and I should have one of them over
here.
Copy.
And now because this is a secret, has
to know how to encrypt it.
We just pass in our password.
And if we take a look at that,
you'll see that
without knowing what the decode encryption secret is,
that is just not available.
We do have a comment, so I'm gonna
drop that on the screen. Siam says, hi
Tom.
Thanks Siam. I feel fantastic. Hey Siam. Cheers
mate. Okay.
So
we've added one bit of configuration. We're passing
the project ID. We wanna be able to
consume that and spin up a new bare
metal server.
We have our off token which is encoded
or encrypted
with our secret that is specific to this
environment. I can add new environments, new stacks
as Pulumi calls them, dev staging, etcetera. They
all get a different secret encryption store.
Alright. Let's go back to in fact, here's
one of my pet peeves that is completely
not important to this episode but I'm gonna
do it anyway.
Is that I don't like code to just
live in in this arbitrary crappy top level
directory. I like it neatly tucked away inside
of a source directory
and we need to tell Pulumi
that our main has moved.
So we can just do that like that.
Okay. What else do we need? Let's come
back in here. So Pulumi API for Equinix
metal.
We
wanted to find some sort of server, so
I'm just gonna call this an NGINX server.
We have access to the Pulumi and because
this is real code,
know, whether you use TypeScript, JavaScript, Python,
Net or the goal SDK,
auto complete and language server protocol is available
for all of these language. And this is
one of my favorite things about writing infrastructures
code this way is that I can get
auto complete
not on Pulumi though, that would be clever.
So device,
now I need to give it a name,
so I'm just gonna replicate engine x server.
And then everything else that we need is
passed into a
key value pair, a map, dictionary, depending on
what language you're using.
Now the reason I choose TypeScript is because
it has actually got all of the type
information
as part of this. So when I do
auto complete,
he says as it fails miserably.
We should be able to get
nothing. Now that's because I missed a step,
I think.
Let's see what it's complaining about.
Host name.
Oh well, let's just keep going. So let's
give this a host name nginx
server.
And we have the red bad stuff, so
is it gonna tell me it's not callable.
Ah, that's why my auto complete is not
working. I have to instantiate
the class.
Okay. So now I should have auto complete
and I do, so we can say facilities,
where do we wanna spend this up? Let's
do AM
six,
if I could type.
We're gonna need to specify the plan, so
I'm gonna do a,
but it's guessing some of them, these this
auto complete list is not up to date
with all of the plans that are available.
So I'm just going to ignore
and pick one that I know is available
in this facility.
And is there any other required things? I
believe we need billing cycle of hourly.
We'll need operating system
and I'm gonna go with
Ubuntu.
Now I know 20 o four is available,
so I'm just gonna take it.
This
I think it's trying to tell me that
it's not aware of these options and I'm
gonna ignore it and see what happens.
The facility is complaining because
it wants a list of facilities.
And now it's telling me that that facility
doesn't exist, but again I think I know
better, hopefully.
Now I'm not actually sure if Pulumi is
gonna tell
me that it can't do that because
these aren't up to date, but we're gonna
find out.
Okay, what else do we need? Let's add
some arbitrary user data,
so we can just say echo hello.
And
it will need a shebang, otherwise the provisioning
will fail.
And we
can
very similar to something in terraform if you're
familiar with it has outputs. We can say
that we wish to export something and I
want to export the NGINX IP address.
And I can get that there on NGINX
server,
dot access public IP v four and that's
now a variable that is available to me
when I run Pulumi stack outputs.
That all makes sense to you both?
Yeah. Okay.
So
export.
I'm failing at TypeScript today, cons. That's better.
Okay.
So let's see if that runs.
We can run a Pulumi
preview.
We give it our decryption code
and we'll see how much it's gonna yell
at me. Okay. So
We got a little bit of feedback.
Yeah. So it's just telling me that my
string list is not assignable to an input
facility list.
Okay. So it's actually validating those types. So
I'll need to reach out to the Pulumi
people and see how we can improve that.
So for now, let's use ones that it's
happy with.
Let's
go with the c two medium
and we'll just drop this down to 18.
Woah, that's angered the beast.
Project ID, okay. So now we have to
consume
our project.
So just setting that makes it happy but
right now we have not actually got the
ability to inject this. So how does that
work in Pulumi? That is a great question
if I can remember. So we can do
a Pulumi equals
Pulumi
config.
So is it new?
Yes.
And then from here we can say require
and
we are gonna require it, so when you're
working with config in Pulumi, you have the
option of saying get which
will allow you to set some sort of
default value if it doesn't exist by setting
require I'm saying the stack will not be
able to spin up if this does not
exist and I can request project ID
and I'm not actually sure what happens if
that fails, so let's save this.
I didn't mean to close it
and run that again
because I've never done that before.
Yeah. Missing requires configuration. Awesome. So when I've
thought what happened, definitely.
So we fix that, we run preliminary preview
again and we give it our decryption password
and hopefully now it should tell us that
yeah. Right? We want to create a new
stack and we're gonna deploy some sort of
NGINX server.
So that is what
I'm expecting. That is is what I'm comfortable
with.
So we can move on
and instead of preview, we jump straight into
and Pulumi is a terraformer up. Pulumi
up. The language just changes slightly between the
two tools. They're very similar.
So now we just get one more confirmation.
Are you sure this is what you wanna
do?
Let's say yes.
And this is the the boarding bit. This
will take
a minute or two. So if there are
any questions, I'll take them from the team.
So does this update you on the process
like it would if you were
in the API or doing it from the
UI?
Yes. There is
is feedback being delivered to Pulumi.
It's not as we're not gonna get that
nice timeline view that we get from the
Equinix metal console.
But I don't see any reason why that
couldn't be relayed back. So Pulumi is actually
working on events that are happening within the
API. It could be requesting feedback on that
and it could display here. You see where
there's info here, it's already doing that to
a certain degree. I've got it obviously kind
of going off the screen, but we could
run that without a pager and probably see
it. So I think there's definitely potential to
improve it.
Yeah. But we just kinda need to wait
until it says it's happy for the time
being.
So now is the time you go make
the coffee,
look outside, that sort of thing? Well, it's
just one device. I'm hoping I don't need
to go get some coffee. But why don't
I open a
new tab and pull up the console and
see what happens?
So the the UI element that you're talking
about
is this little differ on it loads. I
want obviously
challenged today.
Which we covered in-depth last week. Right? Yeah.
We talked about it last week. So you
can see you got a nice timeline of
the events. Right now we're just waiting for
this device to reboot
Nice. Which actually started
you know, a moment ago. Once that comes
back online, it will dial home and say
hey, I'm back online and then we can
consider this device provisioned unavailable.
So we're not far away
from the Pulumi point of view, it doesn't
know that we're we're ready yet and that
would just be once this trickles through.
But you can see already just from this
UI like the host name is what we
asked it to be, we've got an IP
address which we'll confirm in a minute. We
are in the region that we specified, the
plan like you know, it's it's all very
almost trivial to a certain degree. Especially
having something like code or complete to help
you do it, which is pretty
useful.
And you can do a lot more with
Pulumi. Right? You can set up to do
multiple servers. You can do.
Right? That's an awesome point. Now because this
is just a programming language, right? There's actually
no reason why I can't do a really
awful imperative list of imperative for.
That's not what I want to. Alright, I'll
just type it manually. You know, there's no
reason we can't do, hey I equals zero,
I is less than or equal to six
and I plus plus
assuming I know how to defend
this stuff anymore.
I don't think I've ever done this still
for loop in a in a TypeScript before,
so maybe there's no.
It's a const, well that was silly of
me.
Okay. That's better.
So you know, I could actually encapsulate this
in a function. Right? So let's just say
that we know what an NGINX server looks
like and I can say const create
nginx server
equals a function
like
so.
Now
this will work.
Let's say create engine x server.
Only our exports not gonna work now, but
what we can do is just say,
yeah,
cost is fine.
Server equals and then we could export it
here. So export const nginx IP, although now
we're struck in a weird situation where we
cut multiples.
So
let's just do
as a list,
so NGINX IPs
looks like this.
And then we're just gonna add to this
push
server.
This is awful code. Please never talk to
this.
I did say it was I did say
it was we're getting dirty. So this is
you're living up to the promise that we
made at the beginning. I am. Okay. So
what I mean, let me, I'll show you
the stack output from the previous run before
I run this again. But you know, what
you can see here is that we've encapsulated
that logic into a function which we could
publish to MPM. We could just store in
another file. We could import to entities. Right?
We can we can really decouple and group
the specific parts of the code that we
need. Now the challenge here is that this
host name is not unique, so we could
accept a parameter. So we can say, hey,
take a
an I which is an how do you
do it?
Do do number.
And
here we can actually interpret this so we
could say this is
NGINX server
I
well then this is now telling me, hey,
you've got a problem here. Let's expect some
parameter and we can just pass an I.
So
now this is templated in a way that
it's actually gonna work.
Okay. So this have NGINX server one, two,
three, four from that then, right? Yeah. This
is gonna have NGINX 012345
just based on the way the loop is
configured.
Poorly configured. I will take credit or discredit
for that. But
our command did finish here, right? So Mhmm.
If we scroll up, you can actually see
we have our output, we have our IP
address, we've seen all these API calls being
made. I can run Pulumi stack output.
I can just request the engine x IP
And now that's a very scriptable output that
I can use in other automation that I
need.
However,
we did just make a whole bunch of
modifications. Now if I was smart, I would
have shown that the way the graph is
produced
here,
in fact let's just do that.
Yeah,
let's do this. Okay, so if I had
move to this first, right?
Just move this out of the loop. I'm
gonna bring the loop back, but I wanna
show something first.
So while a lot of code has changed
here,
the output, the graph that is generated
hasn't.
So I'm saying I'm not talking about my
arse here. When I run Pulumi preview,
it should tell us that nothing needs done.
To that. Right?
We've changed a whole lot of code,
but we were refactoring, we were cleaning up
that code. We haven't actually changed
any of the output. We haven't requested new
machines. We haven't changed their name. So in
fact, let's put this back
and what I've actually realized as well while
I'm kind of running through this horrible horrible
code
is that we're actually gonna end up with
a conflict with this version too.
Right? Even if I add in the host
name is gonna be different and I'm gonna
use this I variable and what we never
actually templated was the resource name itself.
So if I try and run a preview
now, it should hopefully fail
trying to create six devices with the same
ID or URN as Pulumi calls it, unique
resource
thing.
So we've got duplicate resource.
So what we can do is just template
this too. Alright? So NGINX server and we
just do the exact same
and we'll call this I.
Now,
things have definitely changed.
So
we run preview, Pulumi preview,
we enter our code
and you can see it's gonna remove this
old one because all the information changed.
But now we're gonna create NGINX server 031.
I don't know why that's not an order.
There's a lot of asynchronous code happening in
the Pulumi provider here, so I guess that's
to be expected.
But that's just gonna work. So now we
can run Pulumi up,
we let it go and it does its
thing.
So it's gonna shut down the old one.
In fact, if we pull up a terminal
here,
it's already it's already reloading before I hit
refresh.
But you can see,
there we go.
And because
of the it's it's trying to do this
in a safe fashion, it's spinning up our
new servers before killing our old servers.
So
that's why we're getting NGINX 0123456.
And this one will go away when the
rest are happy.
Does that all make sense?
Yes. It was a bit
it's a very interesting way that we got
there.
Yeah. Like I said, I mean, this is
not code that you'd want to show your
mother-in-law,
but
it's functional. We cleaned it up. We created
a we created a function we can reuse.
We encapsulated logic.
We are doing a lot of nice things
here until this imperative style forward with the
crazy bad stuff but that was just purely
to prove a point. So it's a really
awesome tool working with Equinix metals fantastic. We
are working with the Pulumi team to get
that provider renamed
and we will definitely be pushing to get
that auto complete the facilities and all that
upgraded with our our more modern hardware. So
we are looking into that. But that's it.
So who who am I handing over to?
Who is next? I mean, you just want
to wait and see the goodies spin up,
but I don't think that is particularly necessary.
Right?
Okay. So I guess we're also gonna be
taking a look at a very similar tool
to Bulumi.
Terraform. Is that right?
Yeah. So
I think it will work much in the
much in the same way.
Let's do a screen share here. Share screen.
Gotta show my tips.
Look at application window.
Share that one.
Alright. Let me just pop that in.
Okay.
So much in the same way, you're going
to be working with configuration
files.
And the one in
the metal Monday directory here is called
main dot terraform.
Let's see what's in there.
And so we're going to start with
naming the provider. We're going to use Packet
because at Equinix Metal, we are the artist
formerly known as Packet.
We're working on changing those names over for
but, for for now, still still Packet. Remember
the old.
There's plenty of ways that you can bring
in your API key or your auth token.
It's as it's named here. In this case,
it's already baked into my environment,
but you can put it in a tear
a separate Terraform configuration file,
and there's a handful of ways to to
bring that in.
This, this project ID is important because in,
Equinix Metal, resources
need to belong to projects.
And then we're going to do much as
we saw in the Pulumi version,
set up some configuration for what we're trying
to make. And so in this case, I'm
going to look to bring up five devices.
And
so I have a I have accounts set
to five here.
The host name of the machines, I want
to be Terraform Metal Monday,
and then just a bit of formatting.
This count index is going to
count upwards and
name the host names for each of my
five machines.
Percent percent 02G
here means I'd like a leading zero on
there. So there'll be 01,
0 2, and 03,
and so on.
Describe the plan
as the smallest you can find. I think
we're gonna be about 50¢ an hour at
this at
this point.
Put them in Dallas Fort Worth
location,
though
that's an easy enough one to replace with
any, and then it will drop those anywhere
where it finds the machines first.
We'll put Ubuntu on them,
and the project ID will be the project
ID that we've already defined.
Throw some tags on there so they can
be described.
Red shirt because those are the ones that
can easily die. We're not worried about them.
They'll land on the planet first and disappear
to show the situation is serious. Test
metal Monday in Terraform.
And so the first thing I'm going to
wanna do is initialize Terraform.
That's Terraform
in it,
and
we have a problem.
Latest version of Hashtag Cricket failed to install
the provider. And so it looks like it
wants me to upgrade to version point 13
from point 12.
We'll do that.
Say yes to continue.
And now it has added the
additional information onto the top of
the file. And so what it was looking
for was this.
I wanted it to be called have required
versioning here and packet host slash packet. And
so that versions file will now run on
top of the configuration file that we already
had existing.
If I say Terraform init again,
it will go ahead and do it. It'll
install the provider, which is how Terraform
then talks to the
Equinix metal API,
and it looks like we're good there.
To take in, we're going to run Terraform
plan. That's going to describe the describe what
it's going to then ask the API to
do.
Terraform
plan.
And from there, it says five things to
add. And so
we'll scroll back up here and look. So
device Monday will be created.
We don't know the IP yet because it's
not been assigned one.
It'll be in Dallas Fort Worth.
It'll be called Terraform Metal Monday double zero.
All the same information. There'll be 2001,
zero '2, zero '3, and 2004 because the
list is zero indexed.
I think we can go ahead and
give that a try
and say apply.
It'll look for confirmation.
And then for those
for those machines,
it will
go ahead, talk to the API,
and attempt to
make them. And I think at this point,
I'm going to jump over to
screen application
window.
Does that have to so, yeah, jump over
into the
jump over to the dashboard where you can
see each of those
each of those machines
coming up, and it looks like their configuration's
being written. And then they'll step down through
match install system and the rest of the
other
the rest of the other 11
the other 11 steps.
And so in lieu of sitting here and
waiting for this for
waiting for this wait. We're gonna wait. We're
gonna wait and let
I was going to going to pass to
pass to Tom and then and then come
back once they're once they're up and show
some of the ways that Terraform can then
Terraform can then explore.
Or we can or we can have a
staring contest.
For time's sake here, we're not gonna run
the,
Ansible, but we are going to show you
the
there's the Ansible playbooks are just simple
YAML files.
So I'm gonna pull up and share my
screen and show you the two
show you two quick
Ansible screens. Oh, let's switch away from that
so I do not
there we go. So you see you've got
the
Playbook create here. Shared your screen yet, Tom.
It's a it's coming up? There we go.
We've
got the Playbook. Can y'all see? Here, I'll
make it a little bigger here.
You can see we're very simply we're creating
a an Ubuntu device
as a local host. We're running, we're pulling
my SSH key here
and labeling a tutorial key just giving it
a a simple label for this tutorial.
The project ID I had created was a
DevRel demo.
You give your Ansible server the name right
here. Choose your
Ubuntu server.
Now
you can use either the you can use
the packet CLI to pull out the
to pull out the
plan name. I'm doing a C3MediumDotX
80 6 here and get the facility at
the D A 3, which is closest to
me. That's down in Dallas.
The
YAML to remove is just about as simple.
We just put in the project ID. We
the the the
name here that we did, which was
Ansible server. Just put the same thing here.
State absent,
run those Ansible playbooks, and you have your
server up or down, whichever you're trying to
do at the Yeah. Perfect. Late breaking news,
those those machines are up, all five of
them. Nice.
I think what's important
here is that the APIs are I mean,
it's a single API. Right? Equinix Meta has
one API that all of these tools are
consuming. So everything we do in Ansible, everything
we do in Terraform and everything we do
in Pulumi, it's all pretty much the same.
It's just giving you the option
Mhmm. To use the tooling that your company,
organization,
your team is already comfortable with. We're just
trying to show you how to leverage that
regardless.
So there are many more ways you could
do this too.
And you can find the documentation if you
look at like the Ansible packet provider or
look up the
the Packet Go and Pulumi provider or Terraform.
There's we've got all of the documentation help
you get started here.
Yeah. For sure. Definitely.
How is your Terraform looking, Jeremy?
All set.
So Ta
da. Yes. Woah. So on the
yep. And you so detailed feedback here on
timing and everything. Right?
Yeah. So what happens is every 10 every
ten seconds, it will, it will report back
in. And so it'll say ten seconds has
elapsed. Machine's not ready yet. Twenty seconds. Machine's
not ready yet. Thirty seconds. And so on.
It looks like
host number two came up
after two minutes and twenty eight seconds, and
then the last
and then the last four of them were
only
another twenty seconds another
twenty seconds behind.
And so once that
once your Terraform plan has been applied,
you can say
Terraform show, and that will give you all
of the
all of the information about those,
about those machines. So now they do have,
public and private IPs.
That is deployed to,
Dell Fort Worth, the Data Center Number 2
as we thought they were going to.
They have the series of host names we
were expecting
and,
all of the rest of the information.
Earlier,
I glossed
over, but if you'd like to
describe a SSH key, singular one that's associated
with the project, you can, put that in
through configuration.
If you don't put that in if you
don't give the machine an SSH key, you're
still going to need to access it somehow.
And so each individual on your team is
going to have their own key
that's then going
if you don't if
you don't upload a key, all of the
keys from your team will then be put
onto that put onto that machine so anyone
from the team can access it.
So when you're doing this with
for example, when you're putting in the different
keys, can you tell who deployed which servers
then?
Correct.
That will be back in the
inside the API you're able to you're able
to pull that out of.
And so you can when you say Terraform
show, you can look at it that way.
If you say
show JSON,
it will give you a
big machine readable big
machine readable chunk that you can then parse
with
j q or your favorite
JSON parser. I often write a write a
filter that when I if I bring up
a series of machines, it will then just
give me the the list of public IPs
for those. So instead of looking down through
the list, there'll be
maybe five IPs there and see if I
can see
if I can pull that out.
Format version values.
Nice.
So I guess we'll
Yeah. It'll pretty print that, and then,
yeah, we can we can do a more
thorough
walk through of JSON filtering later, but I
get the get the idea.
Yeah. So, I mean, the goal with these
sessions is to kinda walk people through from
zero to
everything. Right? On bare metal. Like last week
we covered using
Equinix MEL API,
using the go tooling and using the CLI,
know, recovering Ansible,
Pulumi and Terraform now.
And then next week, we're gonna take a
look at how we can actually install and
provision our software or our docker containers or
whatever is that we need to get on
that machine using a bunch of other tools
as well. And we're just gonna keep this
content coming.
Right, team?
We are? Absolutely.
I I suppose the yeah. As we're getting
closer to the end and closing out here,
the reminder is to also, like, the last
part, Terraform destroy.
Put it right. Remember to remember to put
away your toys. And so
and so you don't have a so you
don't have billing surprises or things you're not
expecting.
Everything that you can bring up with with
a configuration
is
brought down the same way when you say
destroy. So these are the machines that are
gonna be removed.
Yes to yes
to go ahead with it,
and they come down much much faster than
they go up
Destruction complete after two seconds. And so what
was once there is no longer.
Excellent.
I just remembered to run Pulumi destroy too.
We can
if you wanna give this a try for
yourself
and
see how easy it is to do all
of this on Equinix metal, just go to
equinixmetal.com.
And when you're signing up, use the
promo code all uppercase
metal monday, one word, and you'll get a
hundred dollars in credit to spin up and
and try out everything that we're showing you.
Meadow
Monday. Hold
on. There
it is.
Alright. I can work.
Go away. There you go.
Alright. So we'll leave this open for a
couple of minutes. If you do have any
questions, if there's any content that you want
to see coming out of of this
out of these streams, know, hard questions. The
harder the better. Anything you want us to
solve and show you how to do, we're
happy to do that. So we'll give it
a few minutes. Drop your questions after none.
We will say our
goodbyes
and we will be back next week.
We need some music or something for this
bit. The drums.
Journey. What? It's trying to hit the drum
for us. The drums, I've just got the
how yeah. Halloween, one of the one of
the treats that we got is the
we got these these little go with
We'll go with that to take us out.
And just so you know, that sounds as
awesome as you think it as you would
think it would on this side.
Thanks, Macay, for hosting us today.
Alright. Well, no more questions. So we will
be back next week. Thanks again, everyone. Have
a great day. Until next time. Happy Monday.